thank you ladies there is a new
residency at the wynn and this one you
can enjoy from anywhere rocky is taking
a tour of blue wire podcast studios
where they're empowering podcasters to
success and giving vegas a new kind of
show
so imagine walking through the wind
casino floor looking to your left or
your right and seeing your favorite
athletes being interviewed by your
favorite sports host welcome to blue
wire studios kevin you're the owner
founder of blueir studios this i guess i
could call it a podcast attraction at
the window oh a residency rocky thanks
for stopping by today we'll give you a
tour and tell you all about the fancy
things we're going to be doing here all
right i'm excited first and foremost i
got to know more about this really great
mural oh yeah carly jackson a
sports artist really approached us with
this idea how do we get some of the most
inclusive voices athletes in sports enis
kanter gus kenworthy a bunch of people
up here and yeah i think this really
stands out when you walk in absolutely
so who is blue wire what do you guys do
here so we are a podcast focused sports
media company we have 175 podcasts some
with athletes some with influencers some
with celebrities and the wind contacted
us in january wanting to know if we'd be
down for this type of partnership and of
course we said yes yeah how could you
say no okay how do you turn that down oh
no yeah we were shocked and floored this
was obviously a expensive
building to create and really pump to be
partnering with them all right so where
does all the magic happen let's head
into the actual studios to see
how the podcast works oh yeah what kind
of shows are you going to be putting on
so next week we have michael phelps here
he'll be recording with one of our
podcasters david meltzer we have the
sports
gambling podcast network in here today
we're launching a couple shows with wyn
bet to win presented by win vet as they
really try to get into the digital space
and
listen we'll be here for nba summer
league for this
nfl draft there'll be content going here
all the time okay what's the future of
blue are obviously today is the launch
congratulations but what's the future
what can we expect future is going to be
game shows and comedians and even djs
competing inside of the studio
sports will be the crux but we want that
vegas vibe we want to be entertainers
and really see
us ourselves
branching out from sports so that's
that's why vegas is the perfect place
for blue wire studios so how can people
listen tune in
bluewirepods.com is over our website you
can search bluewire wherever your
podcast and really appreciate you
stopping by and hopefully the listeners
will come check it out oh thank you so
much kevin i'm excited for you guys tap
in i'll send back to you
thank you rocky i hear they have the
number one raiders fan podcast on their
network too so you might want to check
that out las vegas now we'll be right
back